avanza con mucha calma Santiago por
fortuna y hasta el momento Aunque sí se
han registrado algunos choques entre
ciudadanos en los últimos días sobre
todo anoche pero hoy en lo que es Sao
Paulo cerca de la avenida paulista Pues
la verdad es que la jornada está
tranquila detrás de mí está el hotel
intercontinental de la paulista es aquí
donde Lula da Silva ofrecerá
declaraciones fue cuando finalice la
elección gane o pierda Y si ganara pues
estamos justamente a una cuadra de la
avenida paulista donde saldría a
festejar con sus electores en tal caso
ahora esta mañana como ustedes bien
decía Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva efectuó
su voto lo hizo en San Bernardo jucampo
a las afueras de Sao Paulo y después se
procedió a dar declaraciones a los
medios de comunicación Allí se refirió a
este episodio tan sonado este sábado de
la diputada Karla zambelli del lpl que
persiguió con un arma un periodista al
que acusó de maltratar y de violentar
más específicamente de violencia de
género cuando ella intentaba convencer a
a una votante Esto fue un episodio pues
muy grave Porque además en estas 24
horas estaba prohibido el porte de armas
antes de la elección y Lula se refirió
al episodio diciendo que precisamente
Ese es el Brasil que no quiere el pti y
que ellos van a competir y que no
debería tener una diputada la necesidad
de portar un arma para defenderse ahora
el otro episodio que ha sonado mucho el
día de hoy son los o más de 500
operativos que ha realizado la Policía
Federal en las carreteras esto teniendo
en cuenta que el de Tribunal Superior
electoral ordenó que el día de hoy el
transporte fuera gratuito para facilitar
de que los ciudadanos especialmente en
zonas de periferia y en zonas Rurales
pudieran desplazarse hasta los centros
de votación entonces pues bueno es una
denuncia grave porque significaría que
se estaría impidiendo a los votantes
llegar hasta sus puestos de votación por
lo demás pues avanza la jornada nosotros
vamos a quedarnos aquí cerca del
intercontinental vamos a conversar con
la gente y seguro estaremos hablando
cuando cierren las urnas